- He was 6-foot-5 with a bolo tie
and a face that was downright...
punchable.
- Motherfreaking L.A. traffic goshdarnit.
Hey, can we stay with you?
StubHub center is hosting a flipping soccer practice.
Nobody fluffin' respects us.
We're the G.D. front-runners for an AFC Wild Card.
L.A. can kiss my tuckus, I'm staying here.
Yeah, OK, let's leave.
HEY, IF Y'ALL CAN JUST BEHAVE, I'LL BUY Y'ALL CHEESE FRENCH FRIES
AT THE FUDGIN' FOOD COURT!
- Thanks, Dad!
- FUDGE THE OFFSEASON.
I WANT FRICKIN' FOOTBALL!
- Phil, Phil, PHIL, PHIL!
- Win this for me, son.
Pro Bowls and memories, that's all you've got.
AH, FUDGING BRADY
STOPPING ME FROM BEING A G.D. H.O.F.-ER.
- Calm down, Phil!
- FUDGE.
- Jeez, we get it.
- Ah, FLUFF.
Welcome to a meeting of the fluffing losers club.
Flipping CLOWN not gonna fudging get ME.
Can't frickin' believe we gotta save the G.D. day again.
OK, well Larry is clearly a Hall of Famer, right?
- Eli has the rings.
- But Phil's consistency, my God!
- [All three:] AHHHH!
- Everyone doggon loves you.
Hey, 2004 Eli, F--k you.
- WOAH.
- I'm a Hall of Famer...to my friends.
What the fluff is a Charger anyway?
HEY, YOU.
YEAH, ALL FREAKIN' HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOU
Flipping listen to me.
I'M P.O.'d about the M.F.ing lurkers watching our B.S.
So subscribe to this G.D. channel or G.T. the fluff O.
Daddy says subscribe.